you get a primal response when someone's
coming at you from the back and you
can't look at them
one of the coolest game ideas i've ever
heard the perseus versus medusa
challenge and
let me tell you this game is bone
chilling here let me tell you a little
bit of history so perseus a young hero
he's got winged boots he's got a sword
he's got a mirror shield why well he's
going out to fight some lady called
medusa who's medusa well medusa is a
fair dame who uh poseidon once had his
eye on but medusa was like no no thank
you no thank you poseidon also her
sisters were like yeah none of us want
you and so poseidon got super pissed
gave him snakes for hair and made it so
that whenever anyone looked at their
face they would turn into stone things
were really different back in the day
different set of standards so
don't judge the people of ancient times
by today's standards okay the person
playing as perseus will have a sword
they will have a mirror representing his
mirrored shield which he used in legend
i'm going to have a sound effect i'm
going to play it
and when anyone hears that that means
they have to freeze they turn into stone
if i look at him
he hits the button and i freeze yeah
let's say he's you and i'm like this i'm
still good yeah you're good because
you're not looking at it oh man this is
bad this is so bad
no
oh this is so rough
this is so unfortunate
wait why am i going back here
[Applause]
are you afraid right now a little bit
come on
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm packing up because we're headed to
big apple new york city we're actually
heading out to film a commercial for
battlefield v when i say commercial you
might think about the last one we did
where we went out and blew up a bunch of
stuff with tanks and jeeps this is
actually gonna be a little bit different
this time this is actually more of a
community based project we're going to
be actually going out to new york city
to hang out with a bunch of people from
the gaming community at casey neistat's
368 studio we are going to be playing a
ton of battlefield 5. we're going to try
and make a super compilation that means
we're going to be finding the craziest
gameplay moments and basically making
the coolest compilation video for
battlefield 5 you've ever seen this
isn't going on more than just online
this is going on tv too that means this
is a big deal so for us we want to be
super prepared so we head out tomorrow
morning we're gonna bring two reds we're
gonna bring two tiny little lights and
we're also going to swing by b h because
there's some gear we need there
subscribe so you can see what happens
and what goes down in new york
we're
co-squiring
dude i went to the gym for one day and
this is how i came out people in greek
times had more abs on the side and then
they also had a little
pooch from drinking so much wine
that's where the pooch comes from
heard this is the layer of medusa and
her sisters
markings on this door
[Music]
this is inverted so i can't oh god
[Applause]
like i saw you and i was looking at you
through the mirror but then when you got
close my instincts just took over and i
looked and i looked right at you here we
go my plan of action is just backwards
katana move
i don't know what i'm like i'm getting
in the mood like just never looking at
people look at you in the mirror okay
obviously has a dead body out there
[Applause]
everything's reversed which makes it
really difficult
strange noises coming from this cave
here
[Music]
i think he left
dude this is just like a haunted house
i was getting tired holding this mirror
up the whole time
[Music]
i see what you're doing
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
surprise zombie attack hitting him
him realizing he's all skinny yeah yo
he's going oh hey everybody what's up hi
guys hey how you guys doing excellent i
don't remember hey jake nice to meet you
yeah i love your work thank you so much
so can we uh do something right yeah
yeah let's do something
cause it's a camera there
okay
bye everybody
this is nice nice chairs nick what are
you doing you're not gonna film this are
you no this is a separate thing this is
a whole different channel you know this
is not your thing anymore you gotta get
out
all right who's going to die next
jared
for the honor of greece i'm going to try
to take the gorgon's head i feel like i
liked nico's turn and like
lunge was pretty good but that's very
risky the gordon awaits
you're mind
i almost turned and looked at him too
like i was like almost there i was like
oh did you get the chills when you saw
me it was so creepy you guys was like
okay i'm like haley
i'm all wet now
my heart's like my heart is pounding
when medusa died one of the things that
was born as a result of her death was
pegasus nice so here you go
you should know the pedal when you're on
this all these spirits
[Music]
make sure you subscribe to quarter crew